in this episode of taking on your
craziest challenges we create the drill
racket try playing one versus four and
them the world's longest serve and more
let's get into it okay it's going to be
me against four with one ball my first
victim or is
it oh one
zero you can't out cover this I can't
protect
all nice nice nice
I was thinking who am I going to hit it
to okay let's make it harder four Ries
at the same
time got my eye cuz you have no idea
where the ball is coming from keep your
eye on the ball I kept the eye on the
ball keep the eye on the ball he took
the advice
[Music]
literally
next up cross
shape what finish
it what a
no next challenge is to tape our hands
and legs together but let's rewind a bit
to see us struggling with the challenge
no no but but right
hand okay that's the one this feels
really awkward it looks like it
too
introducing team a
of oh
we they're not that
fast nice you yes
me like my hand came off
this is the next level this will be so
hard the human
windmill
yes now to the next challenge so next up
we're going to go and check out the
pongfinity smash racket that we can find
in one of the biggest department
department stores in Finland it's the
first time ever that our racket is in a
department store so this will be pretty
exciting if you're from Finland
Gaga smash I've got a challenge for all
of us who can find our racket first 1 2
3 go
okay oh here
here look at that that's it that's a
racket oh that's super cool that's a
really cool to seea the first time ever
it has been a huge milestone for us to
get it into a physical department store
and we would love to see this in other
countries too so if you have any
contacts who could help us get our
racket into a store in your country send
us an email and we'll try and make it
happen and of course you can still get
the smash racket from our web store on
to the next challenge this is either the
dumbest or the smartest idea we've ever
done
oh no no no I have a bad feeling about
this I think it will stay there
oh I don't want to be too close to that
this might actually be pretty dangerous
oh
let's
what that's a disy tactic it
works
[Music]
it's go
far
nice let's see what happens if we
drop okay so we have 45 balls lined
after each other so that every Ser is
further and further everybody has three
lives who Will Survive the longest okay
first serve don't miss it don't miss
it oh
nice oh
nice o I felt the pressure why is this
so scary
[Music]
closer that almost was too
short oh why is it so much more pressure
like this it's
weird
swi number 13 that's done still
bouncing
ni
yes now there's two on the table got to
put some power into this
one nice yep
oh we're already quite
far that's it that's it and on the table
joining the
collection 12
M that's it that's it yes oh
easy easy for you guys that's good
that's safe that's
safe that's good that was the perfect
one
come
nice what really nice I can feel Otto's
heartbeat racing
sa
oh now you really have to put some Force
into it come
on nice
that oh you touched did it touch did it
touch I think it touched
Prett touched not even far away yeah
come
on that's
it oh you got it and it came back how
are we doing this open the gates this
was an unexpected twist okay this is the
new final
level oh much spin stop yeah I think
this this new five levels extra is a bit
too
ambitious yeah I'm out that's my
limit it is
possible nice
oh nice I can't even see the table
anymore the distance is really hard this
is really
hard that's it that's it that's the
one that's crazy that was a good hit
only possible with the Sensei ret we
shall see how this
goes oh no I'm out congrats
Cong we got pretty far I had to say it
was a very fun challenge